All right, let's dive into
today's explainer.
We're looking at a really
provocative idea called
Pluralism and the Dremel.
It completely challenges how we
usually think about American
diversity and argues that what
we call pluralism, well, it
might be a powerful force for
something else entirely.
Wow.
OK, so the source really just
throws down the gauntlet with
his opening line, doesn't it?
It's reframing the whole
conversation.
It says that the friction we see
between cultures isn't always
about simple prejudice.
Instead, it might be the work of
a powerful, almost impersonal
machine of assimilation.
So to really get what this
argument is about, we have to
start with the story we all
know.
You know the official version,
the American promise.
This is the classic pitch for
American pluralism, right?
The idea that this is a place
where you can come bring your
whole self and coexist with
everyone else without having to
change who you are.
But the text we're digging into
today argues there's a huge
hidden condition to that
promise.
This slide just lays it out
perfectly.
On one side, you've got the
promise of true
multiculturalism, but on the
other, you have what the author
calls the reality hegemony plus
flavor.
So what in the world does that
mean?
Let's break down this core
metaphor because it is the key
to this entire argument.
And yeah, as you can see, it all
starts with hamburgers and hot
sauce.
OK, so here's the breakdown.
The text defines hegemony plus
flavor like this.
Think of the dominant culture,
the hegemon, as the main dish.
That's the hamburger and apple
pie.
That part is not up for
negotiation.
Now, other cultures, they're
welcome, but only as flavor.
You can add hot Foss.
You can add some turmeric, maybe
swap in a Turkey Patty, but the
fundamental dish has to stay an
American hamburger.
And this is the really crucial
part.
According to this view, if you
try to serve a completely
different dish with a whole
different set of rules, it's not
seen as celebrating diversity.
It's seen as non compliance.
And that that's when you start
to hear that grinding sound.
Which brings us to the second
big metaphor, the grinding
Dremel.
This is the author's image for
that relentless, powerful
machine of assimilation.
Yeah, that quote from the source
is pretty dark, I know, but it
captures the point perfectly.
This isn't about personal hate.
It's about an impersonal force
that just sands down all the
sharp edges, all the
differences, until everything
fits the mold.
It's the sound of compliance
being enforced.
Now, this isn't just some
abstract theory.
The source points to real,
concrete examples of this
Dreamal at work throughout
history.
You've got the Americanization
schools at Ellis Island, the
immense pressure on immigrants
to change their names.
Even the GI Bill is framed as a
tool that hammered a whole
generation of diverse veterans
into one single suburban
American ideal.
OK, so if those were the more
obvious methods back then, how
does the Dremel work today?
Well, this perspective argues
it's gotten a lot more subtle.
It's shifted from that overt
pressure to something they call
assimilation by sitcom.
The source draws this really
interesting contrast with the
German model, which it describes
as blunt.
You know, honest, here are the
classes you must learn to be
German.
The American model, on the other
hand, is way softer.
There are no mandatory classes.
It's just this constant, subtle
cultural pressure that comes
through our entertainment, and
the prime examples given are
those huge, groundbreaking
Norman Lear sitcoms from the
70s.
Shows like these are framed as
more than just entertainment.
They're seen as a form of soft
propaganda with a very, very
specific message.
So what was the underlying
message?
The source makes the case that
these shows basically taught
America that minorities and
immigrants were funny, lovable,
maybe a little quirky, but
ultimately they were harmless
and fit neatly inside the
existing American structure.
The Jeffersons moving on up
wasn't a call to change the
system.
It was proof that the system
worked for everyone, if you just
played by the rules.
But according to this view, the
deal has changed.
The old American dream was,
well, it was plausible.
A house, a car, a steady job,
the new dream that pop culture
sells us.
It's an absolutely unattainable
fantasy of private jets and
influencer lifestyles.
The author argues that the
latter, to get there, has been
kicked away, which makes that
whole promise of assimilation
feel like a cruel joke.
So that leads us to a really
critical question, right?
What happens when the Dremel
fails?
What are the consequences when
groups can't assimilate?
Or maybe when they just won't?
The source points to what it
calls settlement pluralism.
These are enclaves where you
don't actually need to engage
with the dominant culture at
all.
The concern raised here is that
this starts to erode any kind of
shared civic culture, and that
risks balkanization, where
society fractures into smaller,
often hostile groups.
And the text argues that no
group has experienced the
relentless pressure of this
Dremel more than African
Americans.
For 400 years, from Jim Crow to
mass incarceration, the machine
has been grinding.
And here's the point the source
makes.
You can't sand down skin color.
So the friction is constant.
Black culture as flavor, you
know, music, food, style that's
tolerated.
But blackness asserting itself
as a separate civic power that's
met with the full force of the
machine.
So this all leads us to the
final and maybe the most
challenging part of this whole
argument.
It really forces us to reexamine
what we even mean when we use
the word racism.
So let's just ask the question
directly.
Based on everything we've looked
at, is this constant grinding,
this forced compliance?
Is it actually racism?
Well, the text answer is
nuanced.
It says that yes, individual
hatred and bigotry exist, but
what we often call racism is
described here as the impersonal
sound of the machine enforcing
its own rules to the person
being ground down.
It feels like hostility, for
sure, but from the system's
perspective, it's just
maintaining order.
So the crucial take away is
this.
American pluralism, in this
view, is not true
multiculturalism.
It's not a collection of equal
parallel cultures existing side
by side.
It is a single dominant system
that allows for cultural flavor,
but demands, absolutely demands,
that everyone plays by the same
set of rules in the public
square.
That, according to the source,
is the real deal.
And we'll just end with the
sources final, pretty chilling
sentence which basically sums up
the entire argument.
That grinding sound you hear
when you resist?
It's not a bug in the system,
it's a feature.
It's the sound of the machine
doing its job.
It's a very provocative idea to
think on.